Now we'll discuss Islam in the right
perspective by understanding what is the
concept of God in Islam. And the best
reply that any Muslim can give you
regarding the concept of God in Islam is
quote to you suras
chapter number 112 verse number 1 to4
where Allah subhanana wa ta'ala almighty
God says
Say he is Allah one and only. Allah
Allah the absolute and eternal.
He begets not nor is he begotten.
There is nothing like him. This is a
four-line definition of Allah subhanana
wa ta'ala which is given in the glorious
Quran. Any person says so and so
candidate is God. If that candidate fits
in this four-line definition, we Muslims
have got no objection in accepting that
candidate is God. Which is the first
says Allah and only Allah. Allah the
absolute and eternal.
He beggets not begotten.
There is nothing like him. This is a
fourline definition which I call it the
master key for it is the touchstone for
theology.
Surah class chapter number 112 of the
glorious Quran is the touchstone for
theology. Theom means God lost study.
Theology study of God. And what is the
touchstone?
If you want to buy or sell any gold
jewelry, what do you do? You want to
verify how pure is the gold. So what do
you do? You go to a goldsmith. The
goldsmith takes the gold jewelry and he
rubs it against a stone known as touch
stone. And depending upon the color that
appears, he will check it with his chart
and tell you this is 24 karat gold. It
is 22 karat gold. It is 18 karat gold.
It may not be gold at all because all
that glitters is not gold.
So suras is the touchstone of theology.
Whichever god you're woriing,
put that god to the test of suras.
If that god passes the test of suras,
you are worshiping the true god.
If it fails the test of suras, you are
not worshiping a true god.
For example,
there are
many human beings
who believe that Bhagawan Rashnish is
almighty God. During the question answer
time once a Hindu told me that Hindus
never believe Bhagat Rashnish is God. I
never said the Hindus believe Bhagad. I
said many people believe. I didn't say
Hindus. I'm aware of the Hindu
scripture. Nowhere in the Hindu
scripture does it say that Bhagavad is
God. Let's put this Bhagwan Rajnish who
many human beings consider to be God to
the test of suras.
Number one
say he's one and only. Is Bhagwan
Rashnes one and only? Is he the only man
who has claimed to be God? We know there
are hundreds and thousands of men who
have claimed to be God. Especially in
the country where I come from, India,
many thousands. He's not the only one or
someone says no no he's unique only one.
Let's go to the next test. Allah husat
Allah the absolute and eternal. Was
Rajnish absolute eternal? We know from
his biography when we read
it is mentioned in his biography that
Rajnish was suffering from ama
from chronic back ache from diabetes
malitis. Can you believe almighty god
suffering from amama
from backachche
from diabetes malitis
and the third test lamb is he begets not
know he's begotten we know from his
biography that Rajnish was born in Jabul
in India he had a mother and father
later on his mother and father become
his own disciple and in the year 1981 he
goes to America
And in the state of Oregon he starts his
new village called as Rajnespura.
In 1981 he starts his own village
Rajnishpuram. And you might have heard
at that time in the 1980s he was the
person who had the maximum Rolls-Royce
in the world more than 90.
He did not buy any.
His fans gifted him because he liked
cars.
So the owner of Rolls-Roy went to meet
who is this man who has got more than 90
Rolls-Roy.
He was so famous. Imagine gifting Ross
Roy.
So later on the American government,
they arrest him because he was making a
fool of the Americans. They arrest him
and they put him in prison. So Rajni
claims the American government gave me
slow poisoning in prison. Imagine
almighty god being slow poisoned
and in 1985 he was kicked out the
country and he comes back to India and
in the state of Maharashtra in the city
of Punea he starts his new center Osho
commune
and when you go to a center it is
mentioned on his samadhi
on the stone that oh show. Never born,
never died, but visited the earth from
the 11th of December 1931 to the 19th of
January 1990.
Never born, never died. But Almighty God
visited the earth from the 11th of
December 1931 to the 19th of January
1990. They forgot to mention on the
stone he was not given visas to 21
countries of the world. Imagine almighty
God coming on this earth to visit the
earth and he requires visa.
You and I require visa. Almighty God
also requires visa. And the archbishop
of Greece said if you don't remove right
out of this country we'll burn his house
and the house of your disciples. And the
last test
then nothing like him is so stringent
that no one besides the true almighty
God can pass. The moment you can compare
God to anything in this world, he's not
God.
And we know that like the common human
being had one nose, one mouth, two eyes,
two hands. The moment you can compare
God to anything in this world, he's not
God.
Suppose someone says Almighty God is a
thousand times stronger than Arnold
swashing. You might have heard the name
of Arnold Swasher who was supposed to be
the strongest man in the universe
got the title Mr. World Mr. Universe.
The moment you can compare God to
anything in this world whether it be
Arnold Swasher or Dhar Singh or King
Kong whether it be a thousand times or
million times the moment you can compare
God to anything in this world he's not
God.
This is a fourline definition of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala given in the
glorious Quran. Any person says that so
and so candidate is God if that
candidate fits in this fourline
definition we Muslims have got no
objection in accepting that candidate as
God.